de la musique et de la danse libanaise
dans la cour des commandes du parc du
château de plaisir escale d'ailleurs
concert sa recette gagnante
un festival cosmopolite c'était le
plaisir me plaît la position libanaise
et pour le peuple française
on voulait vraiment accompagner les
familles et surtout le mélange au pic
que nous avons sur plaisir c'est pour ça
que vous entendez des musiques aussi
variés et puis alors y est surtout d
accueil pour les enfants avec des jeux
et puis y'a d'la dans mon seul de la
musique
donc tout ça pour dire que on a visé
particulièrement le mélange des
quartiers et les familles des familles
qui sont nombreux à venir chaque année
ils sont entre 8 et 12 mine à découvrir
des jeux et spectacles originaux
c est des moments qui soit magique des
moments merveilleux où elle apprend
d'autres cultures et d'autres d'autres
traditions et donc c'est très important
de le faire
l'occasion d'observer des progrès de sa
progéniture le conservatoire de plaisir
participent aux festivités avec
notamment la section danse ou si je la
vois correctement jeu n'ont pas
l'occasion de venir parce que féfé
agréable on peut manger on peut jouer
côtoyer des gens et fait vachement
conviviale les différentes scènes ont
accueilli des spectacles jusque dans la
nuit un grand moment de partage culturel
et de voyages